i would say how wonderful my
four-year-old and their imagination is
male gametes that's what makes me male
no your your sperm don't make you male
then what does
it's a constellation
in reality
in truth okay whose truth are we talking
about the same truth that says we're
sitting in this room right now you and i
no
you're not listening if i if i see a
chicken laying eggs and i say that's a
female chicken laying eggs did i assign
female or am i just observing a physical
reality that's happening in the world
does a chicken have gender identity does
a chicken cry okay but but these are the
same people that are gonna say like men
should cry the same as women and that
there's there's no difference between
male and female like the way we dress
like i said the other day
the whole thing is confusing because
like i was saying lesbians are women on
women
i can be a woman that means i can be a
lesbian that means you can be a gay man
maybe i am there you go you could be a
gay man the whole thing is just crazy
it's not making any sense or they'll say
like men can wear dresses
like the outfits don't make it which
basically is saying that dresses aren't
meant for men
they're meant for women but then they
can't art they can't answer what is a
woman
it's it's too it's too confusing though
it's too confusing
i forget people like this exist
sometimes because people around me are
pretty sane right so sometimes i forget
i would love to have her on my show i
would i would love a conversation with
her as well yeah she can commit suicide
let's reframe it because you're talking
you're trying chicken has sex like any
like any biological organisms an
assigned gender
but a chicken doesn't have a gender
identity so we assign females to
chickens when they lay eggs that's it we
assume they're female if they lay eggs
at what age does the medical transition
begin with uh medication so medical
affirmation begins when the patient says
they're ready for it
so that could be
a kiddo who is just starting puberty
and panicking because they're getting
breast buds or their penis is getting
bigger and busier and they're worried
about all kinds of masculine changes and
that way puberty blockers which are
completely reversible
and don't have permanent effects are
wonderful because we can put that pause
on puberty just like if you were
listening to music you put the paws on
and we stopped the blockers and puberty
would go right
back to where it was the next note in
the song
just what's that please they're messing
with your whole biology biology
this is what's so sinister about it for
me is that human beings have a biology
and the fact that they're going to stop
a natural process within every human
being
says that there's something wrong well
and she can't not know that there's
going to be effects you're like there
has to be side effects from that i'm not
a doctor i don't have a biology degree
but it's just common sense if you delay
puberty there's going to be side effects
from that that'll probably last them the
rest of their lives
we said earlier on how can a child at
the age when they start to like when
they start puberty how can they know
that this is a decision that they want
until they're in their 60s no they don't
there are decisions that i made in my
20s i'm like what a stupid decision yeah
you know what i mean it's child abuse i
think
i think it is i think it's yeah i think
any parent that allows that is literally
i would say child abuse 18 you can do
what you want
but you're going to do that at 13. 14 9
10. i was i thought i was
japanese at 13. i said my son was sonic
the hedgehog yeah
what the hell
it's delayed that period of time one of
the drugs used as lupron right which
has actually been used to
chemically castrate sex offenders
you know what
i'm not sure that we should continue
with this interview because it seems
like it's going in a particular
direction well you're a medical
professional i am a medical professional
so you don't want to talk about
the drugs that you give to kids or
again
i'm a physician and i use medication
you're choosing exploitive words
drugs i guess i'm choosing a chemical
word that was in a dictionary that's not
a correct term for puberty blocking i
could like look it up on my phone but
i'm pretty sure if i looked it up
you can look it up on your phone it says
medical definition the administration of
a drug to bring about a mark reduction
in the body's production of androgens
and especially testosterone and i'm
saying as a pediatrician who takes care
of hundreds of these kids when you use
that terminology
she's saying that if you use the actual
definition you're being malignant and
harmful no they're trying to change
definitions
the audacity of these people you think
you have you have the power to change a
word it's the victimhood though yeah
yeah it's like i'm gonna have a normal
conversation with you and as soon as you
ask me a tough question i'm gonna play a
victim oh my god like that's really bad
ooh sorry that's really bad oh no i
agreed to this interview and he's asking
tough question like what the [ __ ] what
did you think what did you judge what's
gonna happen
this is what we do
we get paid to argue what are you people
people people like this is the way the
world is going i'm so glad that we have
an outlet to actually just like what if
what are we saying what if we had to
just sit at home and not tell the world
and not say anything and just watch it
just crumble as we're just sitting at
home no way no way all right
yeah thank god for youtube thanks for
listening guys i love complaining about
these people on camera
say that giving
chemical castration drugs to kids is
malignant and harmful it's about the
context of caring for a child and and
seeing the
the suffering that kids can have that
have not been in affirmative home
situations
so we're going on this journey
boys can be girls girls can be boys men
can be women women becoming men
it makes me wonder
what is a woman
what is a woman a woman is someone who
claims that as their identity
i'm a woman
i claim female and woman as my identity
as you can see i am i'm a man
i'm a fine ass man i'm a fine arts woman
apparently you know what i mean humble
yourself
is it possible i can be a specific woman
so can i be rihanna
i bet you could i mean that can i be
posted
[ __ ]
who could i be
you could be
oh i could be will smith i'll leave
jaden
i'll do it for you i'll be jaina and try
and keep me where you going boy
but it's like these people are crazy i
don't under
and it's just crazy because i don't
think that we should be like
we shouldn't have to say this stuff no a
common sense should be common but like i
said common sense is definitely not
common amongst these people no it's not
no and um like we've already said like
oh you know facts don't care about your
feelings but clearly we're living in a
world now where
feelings trump facts do you think she's
married
if she is she's probably married to a
woman a man
whatever she is married to i feel like
this is what happens when women are
single too long i feel like this is what
happens when feminism takes over the
world yeah that too
but what are feminists they'd be lonely
come on
and then they and then they start to
live in their heads
they start to create these alternative
realities to many people
that was our answer well a woman is
anyone and that was by the way not to
give any spoilers away but
that is
the answer
from the left to the question which is a
non-answer it's the same thing as not
answering at all but that is that is the
answer the woman is someone who says
their will
and of course to everyone who gives me
that answer in the film i have the
follow-up a woman is someone who
identifies as a woman what are they
identifying as and around and around we
go
because they don't have an answer to the
question
this is a
medical doctor
um
who can't tell you what a woman is
i mean this is someone who who
if someone goes to her and says as a man
and says you know i'm really a woman i
want to transition into a woman
she will help facilitate that process
and yet she doesn't know what the word
means
she doesn't actually know she by her own
testimony
when someone says i want to transition
to a woman she doesn't even know what
that means like what are you
transitioning into
she has no idea
wow wow wow wow
oh my gosh
i can't believe people like that example
well